is it wrong for an apple based channel
to say that i am more excited for the
galaxy note 22 than the iphone 14 pro
because of seven specific reasons and
the first one is definitely the design i
am so happy they stuck with the note
design the screen it does go down to 1
hertz to save battery life and it's able
to keep up 120 hertz at the full quality
videography
i want to check out the nightography
that they're calling it nighttime video
we also have the photography side we've
taken a few trips within the last year
and without those trips i really wish
that i had the telephoto lens from the
samsung camera in my iphone four
nanometer snapdragon 8 gen 1 processor
now i don't think this is as big of a
deal as samsung wants you to believe it
is the s-pen it's all built-in and very
useful so i'm really going to be trying
to make the most use of the s pen and
seven is the fact that this might be
possible this year since i won't have
two huge phones it'll be a lot easier to
be able to keep that and use something
else